so you mentioned that you wanted to be a
voice actor from a young age
when did that start then walk me through
the process i'm interested well um
like i i started to i started liking
anime
um because my sister used to like anime
and then so i used to watch anime with
her and um
i wanted to become a voice actor when i
was in a primary school
oh very young very young i didn't even
know that was like a job when i was in
prime minister
yeah i was just like funny acting people
i just thought the characters just
existed
goku's there somewhere in the world
right yeah yeah i'm sure he exists
yeah like um i was watching um bleach
with my sister and you know
yeah yeah voiced by um yeah who's like
she's like a woman and she's like voice
acting a a boy
yeah yeah and so i was really like
fascinated by that and i was like
oh i really want to become a voice actor
and then from then on i was kind of like
um i told my parents um that i wanted to
become a voice actor in japan and
you know like typical asian parents
they're like
um
[Applause]
what is a voice actor i've never heard
of that job before do you need a degree
to get it
and what was interesting was that um at
saturday school
uh i used to get like super low marks
like in my
test right so my parents were like well
like you're getting such low marks
in japanese like how are you like you
know going to become a voice actor in
japan where it's like you know you need
to be really good at speaking japanese
yeah and then so um yeah my parents were
like against me but i was like i want to
become a voice actor in japan so
um yeah in high school i
kind of um started auditioning for like
um the schools or the voice acting
schools in
um japan oh wow okay what would i hate
in high school
i think like 16 17.
wow so like i would like work part-time
and then i'll save money
and then i'll book a flight to japan oh
my god
yeah i was like i was like working like
like
four or five times a week and then like
on like
you know during school holidays i'll be
working like six times a week or like
you know just when the
holy [ __ ] you were really on my grind
yeah yeah i was like super like i want
to become
yeah and then like um and um a lot of
the
places uh told me that because i live
overseas it's kind of like
you know like yeah quite hard yeah yeah
but then um i finally like passed the
audition and they're like you know
please come to
um the school yeah and then so
um i decided to go to japan but um
at that time i was in i was still in uni
okay and
you know like my parents were like well
isn't it better if you kind of like
finish
uni and then yeah yeah
and so i was kind of like yeah maybe but
uh
no
during my um during the holidays i like
worked more
and then i saved up a lot of money and
um you know in australia it's like when
you're 18 you can kind of decide
everything
yeah yourself yeah so like um i kind of
quit uni without telling my parents
i think that's like the worst thing you
can do right it's like number one no no
that's like that's like one step away
from a local holy [ __ ]
i've never actually heard an asian kid
do that i'm just like
i'm just i felt that in my soul man like
a thousand of
thousands of my ancestors just screamed
right there
is this what happens when an asian
unlocks like their final
jesus christ
um it doesn't stop there like i i like i
quit uni
and then um i didn't tell my parents and
you're gonna quit uni like for a while
or was it just kind of like [ __ ] it i'm
doing it well um before going to uni
i was gonna i wasn't really actually
gonna go to uni
but then my parents were like can you go
to uni
and then so i was like okay and then i
went to uni for one year and then
um yeah and um
wait so what was the question like did
you when you went into uni
you're like yeah i'm not going to stick
with this or was it like you just had
enough
[ __ ] live in japan yeah um i went to
i went to the
um the classes there and i was like
not like this hell nah
hell
yeah and then so um i booked um the
flights to japan
um without telling my parents and
um i think around a week before the
flights
i told my parents that
to see you because my parents were so
against
me going oh yeah yeah yeah so um like a
week before um
i told my parents and um by then i had
already like
um booked um the packaging what is it
like
the people who come to take your package
to send it to japan oh yeah yeah
and so um yeah so they just like showed
up and they were like what what's all
this
what's all this thing so you literally
just sort out all the logistics
yeah and then oh my god one day before
like the package goes you're like mom
i'm leaving bts
by the way mom going to japan when you
told them that like boss music start
playing
well my i think my parents weren't
expecting me to like
act in that way because like you know in
school i was that girl that was like
you know i would like study a lot and
then obedience yeah
yeah yeah yeah like psych
yeah yeah and then so when i told her
she was kind of like
okay just like top 10 anime betrayals in
real life right
jesus yeah but then um like because 18
in australia is like you're considered
like an adult but yeah teen in japan
you're still considered
like a child yeah yeah you're right yeah
20.
and then so um i had booked the flights
to japan but i hadn't
um like rented any like house or like
anything
and i was like oh i could just stay in a
hotel until i can um like rent a house
but then
after going to japan i realized that you
couldn't book a house
like you couldn't rent a house when
you're like 18. so yeah
yeah you can yeah you need parents
permission yeah
because my parents were really against
me right they wouldn't they'll be like
like yeah yeah and so um i went through
all my contacts
and i contacted all my friends and i was
like is anyone in japan
like you know living in japan can i like
live with you
like yeah yeah yeah and then there was
like one girl
um that went to the same school saturday
school and she
used this the saturdays were paying off
the evidence man
and then um you know she like luckily
she actually um had a bunk bed in her
room
and the reason why she had a bunch of
just randomly well because um like her
parents would be coming over from
australia to
japan like once in a while she was like
oh i could just you know
have like a bunk bed so they could sleep
there when they come yeah and so
um yeah she was like well i have a bunk
bed and you know
if if you're fine with that then we can
live together so we lived together for a
while and then
i started going to the school there and
that's how it
all kind of started that's that's a
[ __ ] badass story man
holy [ __ ]
that's literally like the equivalent of
like the og
american dream kind of story where you
just like you pack your bags you go to
like la or whatever and you just
figure it out and that's kind of what
you
won't hold me back i got this